hi I'm Ryan I'm going to be watching the
trailer for Christopher Nolan's new IMAX
movie interstellar you might be noticing
this guy's not wearing a shirt well like
Matthew McConaughey says now be a good
time for me to take my shirt off
it's an approved for all audiences hell
yeah
[ __ ] love Dolman a lot we've always
defined ourselves by the ability to
overcome impossible America yeah and we
count these moments the first ever to
fly faster than the speed of sound these
moments when we dared to aim higher will
intersect barriers to reach for the
stars
Germany Lourdes euros dollars to make
the unknown
[Music]
I'm a fireman Quran again these moments
are proudest achievements and they fired
the imagination
would go merica we lost on that last
time you pass we just forgotten that we
are still pioneers Australis didn't know
barely begun greatest accomplishments
cannot be behind us
our density
ah
[Music]
that's it
what the [ __ ] that's all we're gonna
show us I've been waiting forever for
this trailer and all I got was footage
from history and Matthew McConaughey
leaving a farm but I have chills I guess
I'm gonna watch this super dramatic film
that was shot with IMAX cameras not
gonna lie I'm a little let down now be a
good time for me to put my shirt on